[Música]
agora aquela parte em que eu tenho que
revitalizará que a audiência depois do
coffee break
gostaria de agradecer o convite por
estar aqui hoje ao palco silva colega de
longa data e também é um prazer ver pela
segunda vez esta escola que eu considero
uma escola interessante porque tem uma
ligação também com um pouco da minha
primeira digamos que profissão que ir
embora não recepcionada na altura numa
primeira fase foi barrado e precisamente
como falava alguém dois toques
também tive a oportunidade de conhecer
rádio pirata como se chamava as rádios
dos fótons tinha os meus 23 11 anos e
mais tarde parte dos meus 17 a
oportunidade de começar a trabalhar em
rádio e trabalhar durante muitos anos
embora aspirar ser jornalista jornalista
de guerra que era o que eu queria mas
sim consegui fazer foi animador bandeira
numa rádio e rádio novela no porto mas
qualquer forma foi uma grande escola
para mim e permitiam provavelmente
chegar hoje onde estou também deu uma
ajuda a chegar onde estou hoje a voz das
pessoas nesse caso falamos de votos
digitais
até porque vai falar deste poder da
internet não é ea capacidade que elas
nos trouxe de coabitar nestes dois
mundos o mundo digital online e o mundo
offline é cada vez mais aqui uma junção
entre estas duas áreas que estava
precisamente com esta esta frase é da
minha autoria mas o facto é que os
retrata nos dias de hoje
alguém falava também numa toca antes
antes da minha que somos muito mais
felizes nas redes sociais do que no
nosso dia a dia revela toda a gente
muito mais fãs no facebook no instagram
me do que na vida real mas faz parte
de facto a forma que hoje em dia temos
do meio digital online ter diários
digitais transpor para os nossos mais
directos outros indivíduos que estejam
ligados por meio da nossa rede através
de mensagens também um pouco da geração
y e até agora o mais próximo
inicialmente internet foi um espectro
continuar os meus 11 anos e eu nos
juntarmos todos lá em casa na rua todo o
bairro todo aumentávamos meia hora para
carregar o jogo e ao fim de meia hora de
ganharmos o jogo cinco minutos - mandava
embora para casa para fazermos os
trabalhos de casa ou para o fechar e
portanto vamos falar de uma geração que
é uma geração que migrou para o digital
e uma geração que já nasceu como digital
também e fax falamos de uma geração que
se caracteriza principalmente esta
digital por andar com o telemóvel do
bolso por uma questão de encontrar o
melhor caminho
portanto esta é a geração uma geração
que desenvolveu uma ligação e uma
interatividade através da internet
alguns até no exagero extrema é como o
caso aqui da nossa joana vasconcelos
lembra da rtp que era isso fosse eu o
refugiado tivesse de imigrar o que é que
eu levava comigo e joana vasconcelos no
seu ipod eo iphone do seu tablet por
tantas vezes usamos até esta questão do
digital e do online com algum exagero
mas é verdade é verdade que falamos de
uma geração que à custa também diz tudo
online do digital se tornou mais
criativa não é
[Música]
nos jogos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a internet trouxe não só ferramentas mas
também formas de sermos mais criativos
acima de tudo há a possibilidade de
termos uma geração que nasceu com sua
arte fone as consolas e também os jogos
e o tablet nas mãos do que isso o que se
vê no youtube que talvez no youtube
[Música]
e mais quem fez mais no youtube há muito
que a internet é que o que tu gostas
mais da internet e da televisão
é de facto aquilo que nós chamamos a
geração desta manhã e já não existem
dispositivos apenas querem conteúdo mas
essencialmente os dispositivos estão
habituados são os positivos de testes e
se fosse um filho mais novo tinha três
anos na altura e portanto funciona seu
não haver os médicos a provisão mas fato
é poder fazer quase a polícia deu no
taboo anúncio marti fome
estamos a falar de uma geração que
desenvolveu toda uma série de processos
todos os baseados no meio online
há muita gente não percebeu que estão
entre os táxis e de facto uva não tem
nada a ver nem com os táxis nem cuba
teve conosco utilizadores e coquinho que
escolhemos e com o poder que este vai
nos deu de escolher é que o que achamos
que para nós é o melhor
estamos a falar de toda uma série de
processos do cotidiano de ver com a
forma como viajamos a forma como nos
relacionamos não vou perguntar aqui
cruzou tinga vai ter uma realidade é ela
acontece e é mesmo na forma como
chegamos mais longe na forma como nos
vendemos muitas das vezes falamos uma
geração que encontrar novas
oportunidades vida e facto muitas vezes
em condições existenciais com minha
esposa que é precisamente o oposto de
mim basta dizer que é advogada portanto
para ela tudo o que é papel em si nada
igual
o digital ainda não tem validade o tempo
aqui por enquanto só que às vezes pede
para ir lá dar vasculhar o perfil no
facebook com 11 11 ex marido de uma
cliente
a versão se adaptar bem ou mal mas
proteção nessas fases mas tava dizer tem
algumas funções assistenciais com minha
esposa quando falamos de em relação ao
futuro dos mil dias em que para mim é
perfeitamente normal um deus seria o
tubo ou ser blogger e acha que não vai
ficar louco tanto jogar vai ser ver com
uma arma e matar uma série de pessoas
mas de facto esta é uma realidade trouxe
novas oportunidades de vida em várias
áreas não é como o caso aqui do que com
ela
ainda mais um novo vídeo que é um outro
barco mais uma doença em portugal
portanto apesar de distante é questão
digital nomeadamente online trouxe-nos
forma para nos unirmos com outros
indivíduos para lutarmos a nível de
causas e acima tudo e muitas das vezes
para enfrentarmos marcas nessa estamos
bem como a marca sua marca nos faz
sentir vai pra uma razão nós temos todo
o poder e legitimidade e ferramentas
para atingir a marca como nunca
aconteceu numa outra altura aliás no
lançamento da nova imagem da nossa ou
precisamente uma onda de críticas e
digamos que chacota a nova imagem até
porque é igual ou pra aos pratos estavam
a ser vendidos no continente
os pratos no serviço moça não é e
ninguém conseguia acreditar como é que
uma empresa paga milhões
milhares de euros para investir numa
nova imagem quando está tão próximo de
um serviço vossa vida no continente por
apenas 90 não é e portanto esta questão
da internet dados também este poder
aconteceu recentemente no aeroporto da
madeira não é composto pelo cristiano
ronaldo
ao que resta saber e e possivelmente
daqui por uns anos podemos ter estudos e
e teses que estudam este nome será que
foi positivo ou negativo
o aeroporto da madeira e é o que vamos
ver daqui por uns anos embora não seja
daqueles que preferem falar bem ou mal o
que interessa é que fala mas acho que
vai ser um cristão e esta questão este
poder que muitas das vezes começa no
dito ao ultrapassar digital e vem para o
mundo offline facto mundo nós vivemos o
dia a dia nas ruas assinantes frente a
frente por uma questão de muitas das
vezes de desenvolver calças é e causas
como a primavera árabe aconteceram
precisamente porque o povo poder redes
sociais como twitter entre outras para
juntar movimentos fora dos países onde
conseguiram fazer essas revoluções
estamos a falar de uma geração com uma
linguagem formas de comunicar muito
próprios
o filho mais velho que eu peguei no
canal do youtube
portanto foi a forma
mostrar a sua indignação o homem estava
chateado por dizer pessoalmente o irmão
eu acho que esse programa muito mais no
tempo e vai atingir mais um irmão
estamos a falar de uma geração que
apesar de com o digital fazer algo muito
interessante
às vezes da manhã através do digital é
uma geração muito difícil de compreender
[Música]
ayanna minutos gum
é facto é que entender muitas das vezes
mas vós digitais que hoje em dia uma
marca própria de uma digital de
influência pelo menos nos meios digitais
para e assumir um papel ativo na forma a
mídia se desenvolva e também na forma
como são desenvolvidos está nas mãos de
uma geração como vocês porque de facto
neste digital plataformas nós não
estamos preocupados vamos ver na
plataforma abc no computador cada vez
mais que hoje em dia as 8 horas quando
vemos no jornal
já estivemos em contato através das
redes sociais através de sites de mídia
enfim no final do dia porque também
temos o vício
eu acho que todos nós temos esse vídeo
hoje os indivíduos móveis entre
plataformas à procura de facto de
experiências de entretenimento na área
dos jogos seja na área de consumir
conteúdos de informação e entretenimento
em
enfim nós hoje em dia estamos em
qualquer uma das plataformas que nos
permita aceder a conteúdos estamos numa
era de fato em que os meios digitais dos
tradicionais acabam por entrar em
conflito permanente mas acabam por se
desafiar hoje em dia temos projetos como
o youtube tv que vai fazer frente a
outros projetos como o canal fox como
uma rtp
o netflix é em nós não estamos
preocupados com isso faz com que nós
estamos preocupados em se ter em
primeira mão um determinado conteúdo ao
mesmo tempo à medida que entram em
conflito os media são obrigados a
coabitar e hoje começamos a ver projetos
como por exemplo este que nascem no meio
digital online e que acabam por ter
lugar nos mais tradicionais entre aspas
na televisão e ao à medida que são
obrigados a convidar de facto estamos a
ceder é uma área uma era em que as
marcas têm que estar atentas e esta é
uma das outras matérias que eu gostaria
de envolver aqui na minha apresentação
até porque ao longo dos anos tem estado
a trabalhar bastante entre marcas no
universo das marcas também e ineficaz
consumidores também as marcas têm cada
vez mais que ficar atentas a todo este
universo quando falta de marcas foram
marcas mais comerciais e grandes grupos
de mídia e hoje em dia tem que estar
todos atentos a toda esta área toda esta
inovação toda esta alteração até por
cada vez mais fato os mais cruzam os
mais institucionais se cruzam com os
mais usados pelas pessoas
hoje em dia qualquer meio de difusão
sejam correio da manhã seja a tsf
seja qualquer outro meio de difusão de
informação têm as mesmas plataformas
qualquer um de nós tem e usa para poder
criar e difundir conteúdo hoje em dia
nós somos o que chamamos os próximos mas
há um grande equilíbrio entre nossos
utilizadores entre nós pessoas entre os
grandes grupos de mídia entre os que até
alguns anos atrás eram os únicos com
poder e capacidade para difundir
conteúdo e tudo isto origina aquilo que
eu chamo novo paradigma nos processos de
comunicação é falamos da era do contente
com tanto martins eu quiser chamar
quando falamos
indicação muito mais associada a uma
vertente comercial uma vertente muito
mais ligado às marcas e falamos daquilo
que é o tema narrativa transmídia ou
melhor o storytelling transmídia
história intel em história em que é uma
base porque hoje em dia está na moda na
boca de toda a agenda embora o
storytelling que pratica há muitos anos
a publicidade historial em um formato
completamente diferente do que o que
agora começa a praticar mas o
storytelling deus sempre praticou o que
é certo é que agora uma zoada da moda é
um búzio e acaba para vender e quem está
no mercado na área do marketing facto
aproveitar são onde essa tendência para
vender um pouco mais de estratégia de
comunicação que esta questão do
storytelling gol porque do historial eo
facto esta questão da narrativa faz
parte de nós quando estamos nas aulas a
forma como é apresentada a mensagem
quando estamos perante um filme porque
estamos a falar com alguém
a forma como a mensagem apresentada vai
nos envolver mais ou menos e por que
está na nossa essência da nossa forma de
comunicar desde a pré história não é o
tempo das cavernas à volta da fogueira
desenhar nas próprias pedras portanto
tudo isso faz parte da nossa forma de
comunicar histórias acabam muitas vezes
até por dar suporte é crenças sociais
vamos perguntar por exemplo qual é a
minha história da humanidade que é como
disse qual é risco dizia onde temos um
protagonista um personagem principal não
é imagine esses dois cristo tivesse um
comportamento martin ao seu dispor
[Música]
hum
o
[Música]
agora
vai dar me back to
era mais ou menos isso que se iria
passar se avatar facto toda a
comunicação fosse nos dias de hoje não é
com o tempo as histórias acabam por
ganhar uma vida própria e é que criam
muitas vezes mitos se eu falar com a
fonte os 60 anos o meu filho mais novo
de sete o pai natal não é igual a
garrafa de coca cola e disser que é o
sonicwall e mostrar como é no wikipédia
e não vai acreditar principalmente vai
ter um dos piores sabor da vida dela mas
farei o que acontece não é tal como o
filme estreou como o orçamento possível
e tornou-se um best-seller de vendas
como de bueiro explodiu é toda uma
narrativa foi contada toda uma história
foi desenvolvida com base em factos em
mitos criados e de repente algo foi
feito propositadamente nós universal as
vendas porque havia muita gente que
pensava e ver um documentário varia de
sobral tem acontecido três jovens
estudantes é importante só de facto uma
história tenha capacidade para
transmitir é envolver as pessoas em
determinadas emoções ela acaba por fazer
a ligação entre a nossa mensagem e
memória das pessoas porque é muito mais
fácil memorizar isso eu não falo nas
histórias da minha mãe conta quando liga
para levantar porque antes de me
perguntar se eu quero adiantar a casa
conta uma história da vizinha que está
doente da minha avó que também foi ao
centro de saúde do meu avô que ainda vai
de saúde para perguntar olha que às
vezes acaba de casa e assim facto as
coisas funcionam
hoje conseguimos que a história de facto
tem um impacto grande por causa desta
questão da narrativa transmídia porquê
porque todas as peças se encaixam seja
através de um jogo seja através de uma
aplicação mobile seja através de um site
através de um vídeo tudo isso se encaixa
em pleno para contar uma narrativa maior
seja uma narrativa de uma marca ou não
ou seja a nossa narrativa e cada mais de
facto transmitir parte da história com
base nas suas próprias características
que são as minhas características do
maio eu tenho plena convicção se
diversas formas de colocar os meus
filhos a estudar através da playstation
serão ótimos alunos melhor que o são por
menos
ainda não é possível mas acredito que
vamos chegar lá é importante os meios de
comunicação juntos acabamos faltam ser e
acaba por mensagem chegar às pessoas
mais impactante e mais pessoas são de
facto expostas cada uma de forma
diferente
a mensagem que queremos transmitir e
tudo isto ajuda a criar uma experiência
única facto com uma marca que nós
estamos a trabalhar para finalizar e se
chama longa no tempo não dois minutos
como tinha pedido mais uns três ou
quatro
o desafio que se que se impõe para
estava deixar aqui estes dois outros
tópicos
o desafio que se impõe às marcas e aos
grupos media na minha opinião não é é
cada vez mais deve envolver as pessoas
na criação e na difusão das narrativas
as pessoas devem fazer parte os tais
utilizados por seus facebook está
grandes né pichetto whatsapp próprios
devem fazer parte não só da difusão da
mensagem mas também na construção da
própria mensagem falava salpicado facto
correio da manhã está primeiro muitas
das vezes notícia antes da polícia a
fazer a reportagem consumar fone ou
muitas vezes até são os utilizadores que
enviam parte da informação para o
jornalista e portanto o jornalista as
farc devem tentar alguma forma não se
confundir com o comum utilizador mas
fazer com que este seja parte do seu
mundo também quando constrói a mensagem
e portanto essas pessoas factos procuram
temáticas e conteúdos do seu em 3 seja
para criar esse conteúdo seja para
consumir esses conteúdos e procuram
narrativas que tenham a ver com seus
tios vida com suas forma e maneira de
estar na vida isso nós utilizamos
procuramos criamos e difundimos nas
nossas redes sociais ou em redes de
terceiros
sentimos muito bem como nos relacionamos
com marcas que acabam por contar
histórias é que o que nós chamamos
histórias verdadeiras
embora possam ser histórias
desenvolvidas ficcionalmente são
histórias tv quadro ainda marca o tempo
e com filosofia da marca e fato essas
marcas que agem com personalidade são
marcas que nós nos identificamos com
marcas que agem tal como nós indivíduos
e fax ou marcas que nos ajudam a criar
ligações com outras pessoas é o caso da
toms shoes é um exemplo que eu costumo
dar uma marca consegue ter um senhor e
numa narrativa uma narrativa tem uma
ligação à questão da responsabilidade
social e da solidariedade
mas com isso consegue unir pessoas de
todo mundo e fazer com que essas pessoas
sejam os principais embaixadores
o uso da marca mais do que contratar
espaço em mídia tradicional fato estas
marcas ajudamos a tornar o mundo melhor
e ajudamos também é ter vossa ter o
poder da voz neste neste mundo
venceu o leão quer
é humana sal fim de noite é quase a
passar aqui venceu a disputa interna
onde ontem 10 ao jogador
pensei uma canção de pagar chalus são
chamados
[Música]
venceu em 2001
o strip tease por furto
[Música]
wisnik para next sempre jogou o revólver
muitas que transformá la rosa
[Música]
pensei que o storm 2006
ao menos ter uma vez em estranhas
[Música]
o ipca se quer
e não dessa forma
[Música]
picas o inter dia 11
esta geração só vocês e facto poder
desta geração está nas nossas mãos os
vossos marte formam na nossa forma de
pensar o digital é apenas mais um meio
para que vocês possam fazer ouvir a
nossa voz
obrigado
[Aplausos]